pierre laurent le secrétaire national du
parti communiste français est l'invité
cette semaine de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
un large balayage de tous les sujets
politiques du moment l'action de
françois hollande et de son gouvernement
que vous combattez tout en vous alliant
à paris avec la socialiste anne hidalgo
l'avenir du front de gauche est votre
relation personnelle au point mort avec
jean luc mélenchon
quel est le prix jean de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire avec
dailymotion et perrine tarneaud de
public sénat
nous rejoindrons tour à tour d'abord
vers le rond jean marc ayrault a à
nouveau défendu ce mardi
l'humanité de la proposition qui était
faite par le chef de l'état à léonard da
alors que le pcf a dénoncé très vite
l'inhumanité de cette proposition et
même l'image est noté a titré sur un
chantage inhumain est ce que vous
comptez sur la mobilisation lycéenne
pour faire fléchir le gouvernement en
faveur de toute la famille
écoutez vos ce moment les lycéens les
lycéens seront en vacances mais ce qui
est certain sur cette affaire c'est que
on ne peut pas demander à une enfant de
15 ans de choisir entre la france et sa
famille donc soit on fait le choix de la
faire rentrer avec sa famille
mais on ne peut pas la mettre devant un
chantage de ce type qui qui qui l'a mais
personnellement dans une situation
impossible
enfin je crois parce que on demande à
une enfant de 15 ans de faire un choix
impossible de faire un choix impossible
d'examiner loin puisqu'elle dit hésiter
et pour cause puisque on la met devant
une situation impossible
donc manifestement devant devant le
doute ou moins je n'ai pas parlé
personnellement avec elle mais je crois
que ce qui est dramatique dans cette
affaire c'est que nous avons en france
des lycéens des collégiens des lycéens
même des enfants plus jeunes qui sont
scolarisés dans notre pays qui sont
parfois depuis plusieurs années ici qui
ont commencé à poursuivre des études qui
maîtrise notre langue
il se sera un gage de confiance de la
france que de les aider à poursuivre
leurs études en france est d'aider leur
famille à s'installer dans notre pays on
ne comprend pas dans l'attitude du
gouvernement dans l'attitude du ministre
de l'intérieur et je ne parle pas des
déclarations la droite et de l'extrême
droite pourquoi on a peur de cette
situation alors qu'en fait je crois que
ce serait je le répète le c'est le signe
d'une confiance de la france en
elle-même que d'accueillir ces enfants
scolarisés la fin mai ce sont les
familles qui réclament une immigration
économiquement pensait que le pays a les
moyens encore aujourd'hui mais je crois
que nous sommes nous sommes dans un
monde où il va y avoir des migrations
des gens qui se déplacent des gens qui
vont qui vivent dans un pays qui vont
aller vivre dans un an et raccompagné
mais je crois que nous avons la france a
eu les moyens a toujours eu les moyens
et c'est très bien accueillir et c'est
très bien organiser la solidarité celle
de l'état mais pas seulement
on sait que dans les quartiers cette
solidarité s'organise
rsf à sa manière le montre donc la
france est capable rsca que les ils sont
capables de s'intégrer je reprends pas
seulement la formulation de manuel valls
vous allez pouvoir revenir sur le cas du
ministre l'intérieur et je reviens sur
le cannet la famille d'ibra rni qui est
quand même sérieusement épinglés par le
rapport de l'inspection générale de
l'administration entre le refus de
travailler du père par exemple et puis
l'absentéisme scolaire des enfants de
tous leurs enfants
oui mais il y a mais on est au met en
exergue et c'est ça qui est dramatique
dans cette situation une famille mais on
sait très bien que la politique la
politique
du gouvernement qui est défendue par
manuel valls procède comme celle qui l'a
précédée avec un objectif de chiffre
donc il faut expulser 18000 vingt mille
personnes par an et on s'occupe pas de
cette question là alors qu'en vérité
on sait très bien que ça n'est pas une
difficulté pour la france de faire ça et
on pourrait très bien accueillir
accueillir ces familles moi je crois que
ce qui est inquiétant situation actuelle
ma carrière c'est qu'en fait oui je
pense et je vais voir dans la situation
actuelle on voit bien qu'il ya une
saturation autour de ces questions
comme il ya une exaspération de
l'opinion mais qui demande également
saturation et mai organisée par des
responsables politiques pour nous
détourner des vrais des vraies causes de
la crise la crise actuelle la crise
actuelle qui met beaucoup de jouer entre
autres la crise actuelle mais crise
actuelle oui il met en scène il l'a fait
avec les rom
il met en scène des des problèmes de ce
type pour masquer que ce qui pose
problème à la france ce qui fait qu'il y
a des millions de gens au chômage ce qui
provoque la division des travailleurs
dans ce pays ça une origine ça s'appelle
le pouvoir de la finance
il y a des gens qui passent leur temps à
organiser le licenciement la précarité
pour des objectifs de rentabilité et qui
s'enrichissent derrière et on ne veut
plus modeste débat dans le pays alors
que c'était le débat central au moment
de la présidence et environs absolument
absolument on désigne les roms comme des
boucs émissaires alors qu'en vérité il y
à des millions de gens qui souffrent
dans ce pays parce que la finance
organise le licenciement de leur famille
alors si je vous comprends bien faire le
rang vous dites qu'il faut arrêter
toutes les expulsions d'enfants
scolarisés oui d'accord donc ça veut
dire qu'on cesse d'expulser toutes ces
familles d'auteurs famille dont leurs
parents en situation irrégulière oui je
pense qu'il faut régulariser à tout le
monde écoutez
mais c'est une proposition que nous
faisons je pense que ça arrive
nationalement mais d'ailleurs le fait
qu'il y ait en france des gens qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient sans papiers qui
soit dans cette situation est un
problème pour tous les travailleurs
parce que ces gens là sont exploités
avec leur situation son papier pour
mettre en concurrence des travailleurs
entre eux et si on régularise s est
travailleur et bien et d'ailleurs c'est
ce qu'avait très bien montré la grève
des travailleurs sans papiers qui a duré
si longtemps en ile de france on avait
vu à ce moment-là surgir de beaucoup
d'entreprises des travailleurs
invisibles qui sont en fait comment
employer par des patrons qui ont pignon
sur rue qui sont des gens extrêmement
connus qui sont des grands groupes et
qui se font de l'argent sur ces pauvres
jouanno si on comprend bien on va le
discours est clair un perdant et si je
réponds ce qu'a dit jean pierre
chevènement vous êtes un sans papier
reste un sans frontières east
oui mais où ai je suis un
internationaliste je suis communiste
internationaliste et ça depuis longtemps
mais ce que je veux surtout c'est que
les gens qui m'écoutent comprennent une
chose ce dont on veut ce qu'on essaye de
masquer dans la situation c'est qu'il ya
50 milliards d'euros d'évasion fiscale
il ya 170 milliards d'euros de cadeaux
fiscaux d'exonérations de cotisations
sociales
il ya des gens qui continuent à s'en
plein la poche on vient nous
parler il ya quelques temps du du
travail du dimanche on a oublié nous
dire une chose c'est que le propriétaire
de ces magasins qui veulent ouvrir le
dimanche c'est la famille mulliez est
une des familles les plus riches de
notre pays et qui sont enrichis toutes
ces dernières années et cette cause
profonde de la crise on veut évacuer
cette question du débat moi je pense que
la france a les moyens
la france a les moyens de son
développement à condition de cesser de
se faire racketter par le pouvoir de la
finance
et c'est ça le vrai problème et c'est
pas la situation de travailleurs
immigrés qui sont eux aussi des victimes
de la misère la france et raquettes un
oui elle est inquiété par les
prélèvements financiers par des frais
bancaires exagérait parce qu'ils
refusent de payer leurs impôts les
grands groupes du cac 40 tandis que les
soins qui s'en réclament et les grands
groupes du cac 40 a cédé rapport
officiel qu'ils disent ils payent en
moyenne 8 % d'impôt quand le taux
d'impôt sur les sociétés est
officiellement de 33% alors ouais pas
répondu tout à l'heure sur la
mobilisation des collégiens des lycéens
est ce qu'elle doit continuer vont
l'encourager mais je crois que
jeunesse et mobilisés spontanément parce
qu'elle n'accepte pas cette situation
mais si les soutenait mais bien sûr les
jeunes de quant à leur manière ont
essayé de réveiller les valeurs qui font
la france parce que la solidarité la
fraternité ça fait partie des valeurs de
la république et ça se vit au quotidien
et c'est ces jeunes lycéens qui ont
manifesté spontanément ne comprennent
pas ce qui se passe parce que ils voient
des copains à eux être expulsé du jour
au lendemain alors qu'ils vivent à leurs
côtés depuis des années sans aucun
problème on leur dit ils sont en
vacances à la toussaint pour l'instant
le combat continue oui bien sûr le
combat est le combat continue et pas
seulement à la rentrée des vacances mais
pour plus longtemps parce qu il y aura
une manifestation yamanaka a lancé le 5
novembre vont la soutenait bien sûr bien
sûr et si je peux y être j'y serai je ne
sais pas si je pourrai y être mais si je
peux y est registre vous y serez antonio
5-1 le pouvoir est assez effrayés par
une manifestation des lycéens et
surveille salle comme le lait sur le feu
l'avons en état les et continuer les
gens qui ont peur de la jeunesse est
toujours inquiétant parce que c'est une
preuve de manque de confiance de l'asie
en one man show parce que au lieu de
faire des grands discours démagogiques
sur la jeunesse il ferait mieux
d'écouter la jeunesse pour la jeunesse
dit on le cur hausse arrêtons ces
expulsions et à la bi raison je pense
que vous avez encore des choses à dire
sur manuel valls 1 où il avait cité mais
à plusieurs fois de cette émission pour
beaucoup même s'il est contesté on le
sait au sein du parti socialiste mais
pour beaucoup notamment les élus
socialistes qui se présente aux
municipales
c'est lui le seul rempart face au front
national et c'est lui qui le plus utile
aujourd'hui à la gauche
et ce n'est pas le départ on parle il
fait partie de ceux qui aujourd'hui
banalise des idées qui nourrissent la
montée de la droite et du front national
parce que en plus il fait des discours
mais il n'agit pas parce que quand il ya
des collectivités locales qui sont
confrontés par exemple aux problèmes de
deux villages
de rome qui ne peuvent pas rester dans
ces conditions qui sont quasiment des
bidonvilles et bien où est l'aide du
ministre de l'intérieur pour travailler
avec ces collectivités locales rue pour
travailler avec ces collectivités
locales que fait-il concrètement pour
régler le problème
où est la table ronde que nous demandons
depuis des mois avec les maires de ces
villes a travaillé nationale analyse le
discours du front national il banalise
effectivement des idées qui sont décidés
d'exclusion quand il dit que des
populations nous n'arriverons jamais à
s'intégrer eh bien ce n'est pas un
discours de gauche et d'ailleurs manuel
valls n'a jamais été le grand
représentant de la gauche je rappelle
que même dans la primaire socialiste il
avait fait 5 % des voix donc ça veut
dire que chez les militants socialistes
il n'est pas considéré que le gros
porteur d'une politique de gauche des
idées
ce qui est inquiétant dans la situation
actuelle c'est que il semble faire la
pluie et le beau temps sur un certain
nombre de décisions de l'elysée alors
que l'elysée devrait écouter davantage
ses électeurs et vous considérez donc
analyser un problème d'autorité face à
manuel valls
mais il il a un problème surtout de cap
de cap politique de cap à gauche c'est à
dire qu'il a l'autorité von est un
problème d'autorité malade qu'il impose
au chef de l'état
bah on a l'impression que qui gouverne
ce pays on a l'impression qu'en matière
économique c'est davantage les marchés
financiers les grands groupes que le
pouvoir le pouvoir socialiste
en fonction de ce qu'il avait annoncé
aux électeurs en là en l'occurrence on
al impression qu effectivement manuel
valls a plus d'importance que tous les
socialistes que j'ai entendu condamné
l'expulsion leonarda donc il y a
effectivement un problème
où est le centre de gravité de la
politique qui est menée aujourd'hui par
le pouvoir socialiste
la meilleure façon de rétablir ce 100 m
dames était pour vous ce serait le
départ de manuel valls du gouvernement
ce serait de ce ca peut on faire partie
il faut changer de toute façon moi je
porte sur lui se verrait sa politique
devront changer parce que moi j'appelle
un changement de cap de l'ensemble de la
politique gouvernementale
donc ça passera par un changement
d'équipé la question elle est plus
global que celle de manuel valls
malheureusement
je m'en vais qui était donnez nous une
mesure forte symbolique qui permettrait
de vous faire entrer dans la majorité
présidentielle je les dis tout un
exemple mais je les ai dit tout à
l'heure il faut par exemple remettre la
main sur les richesses et vague ne sais
pas s'il va que ça on avait promis
prendre une mesure précise on avait
promis une grande réforme de justice
fiscale
eh bien elle non seulement elle n'a pas
lieu mais on à linverse on a
augmentation de la tva augmentation des
taxes sur les salariés et exonérations
croissante
eh bien il faut faire exactement dit mme
aller chercher l'argent du côté du
canada je tiens à rédiger sur les faux
oui il faut venez en moins chez les
15000 à cette entreprise
j'ai proposé au front de gauche de mener
une campagne sur le coût du capital
parce que le problème de ce pays n'est
pas le coût du travail c'est le coût du
capital avant vers un changement de cap
économique c'est clair mais politique
mieux elle réclame un vote de confiance
car la majorité exposé mon rôle est
aussi un vote de confiance dont les quoi
une dissolution
mais la droite la droite elle fait de la
démagogie
alors qu'en vérité quand je les écoute
combattre soit disant les mesures du
gouvernement c'est toujours pour en
demander plus dans le sens des
exonérations pour le capital donc ce
n'est pas avec le retour de la droite
qu'on va sortir de cette situation la
seule possibilité d'en sortir de bonnes
manières
c'est effectivement d'obtenir un cap
sérieux une réorientation complète de la
politique vers la gauche c'est à dire
vers ce qu'attendait ceux qui ont porté
françois hollande au pouvoir et pour y
parvenir je pense qu'il faut leur
mobilisation sociale et elles ne sont
pas suffisantes aujourd'hui mais ça peut
revenir il faut leur mobilisation
sociale il faut leur mobilisation
électorale dont les prochaines échéances
municipales et européennes
un mot sur l'ump qui veut remettre en
cause le droit du sol dans notre pays
est manifestement en mettant fin à
l'acquisition automatique de la
nationalité pour les enfants sont nés en
france mais de parents en situation
irrégulière que répondez-vous à cela on
voit bien que bon c'est une c'est une
déclaration copé pour continuer toujours
pareil à les chasser ou à courir
derrière le des coudes derrière le front
national mais surtout surtout ce sont
des propositions qu'elles viennent de la
droite ou de front national de gens qui
n'ont plus confiance dans la france qui
ne croit plus en ce pays qui ne croit
plus en ses valeurs ce sont des gens qui
ont perdu confiance dans la france et
dans sa capacité à développer sa
jeunesse à accueillir des c'est même pas
accueillir puisque là on parle d'enfants
qui sont nés dans notre pays sur notre
sol et qui devraient pouvoir
automatiquement acquérir l'année il
suffirait tout simplement comme ça comme
c'était le cas à demander il sinon il
suffirait comme c'était le cas avant que
né en france
ils deviennent français ils peuvent
garder aussi lors de la nationalité de
leurs parents et c'était comme ça
pendant des décennies on n'est pas
obligé de revenir sur ça allez on va
évoquer maintenant les municipales ah et
puis l'exception parisienne jean luc
mélenchon dénonce un cas déplorable
dhr alliance dès le premier tour avec la
socialiste anne hidalgo qui va tenter de
succéder à bertrand delanoë alors est ce
que vous auriez troquer votre
indépendance le jugement vient
d'entendre tout aux critiques il y en
aura encore d'autres d'ici la fin de
cette émission contre 13 postes de
conseillers de paris avant d'accueillir
ktm prigent de l' agence france-presse
reportage mais faustine saint geniès ils
sont unis et tiennent à le montrer avec
cette photo de famille bien orchestré
les communistes ont voté pour une liste
avec le ps dès le premier tour des
municipales
comme en 2001 et 2008 anne hidalgo est
aux anges
nous nous sommes reconnus nous nous
sommes retrouvés à la fois sur un bilan
mais aussi sur une ambition et sur une
méthode pour continuer à transformer
paris un accord qui n'avait pourtant
rien d'évident
depuis l'élection de françois hollande
le pcf et le front de gauche se montrent
très critiques envers le gouvernement
c'est donc une rupture avec cette
stratégie ian brossât chef de file des
communistes parisiens intègre même
l'équipe de campagne d'hamid algo mais
il veut tout de même rassuré ses anciens
alliés
le front gauche continue continuera et
je crois qu'il ne faut pas comment dire
dramatiser l'enjeu autour d'une
différence d'appréciation sur les
élections municipales à paris dans les
bureaux de vote certains militants
communistes juge cette décision
incohérente et de peter front de gauche
ont voté contre le budget
l'assemblée nationale et ils ont raison
de le faire ou de la politique de
françois hollande est donc tout ça ça va
nous ça va nous faire apparaître comme
comme n'ayant aucune stratégie propre
indépendante
l'accord électoral reprend certaines
propositions cher aux communistes 30 %
de logements sociaux d'ici 2030 à paris
ou encore la gratuité des premiers
mètres cubes d'eau sous condition de
ressources mais c'est aussi un accord
tactique en cas de victoire le pc n'aura
plus 8 mai 13 postes de conseillers de
paris indispensable pour que pierre
laurent reste sénateur dans la capitale
un accord au rabais pour certains
militants
je pense que tout un tas de personnes
qui sont déçus de la politique de
françois hollande attendent une
alternative mais moi j'ai envie qu'on
leur propose cette alternative à paris
avec un front gauche vaquer à des gels
proposition d'accord parisien devrait
rester une exception
c'est en tout cas ce qu'espèrent les
autres composantes du front de gauche
voilà qu'apple prison de l' agence
france-presse vos questions
alors on l'a vu cette alliance à paris
des boussoles des membres des militants
du pc mais aussi des membres du front de
gauche y en a un qui est
particulièrement déboussolé c'est jean
luc mélenchon il se dit avoir le coeur
ans andré est personnellement et
odieusement trail est ce que vous avez
odieusement trahi jean luc mélenchon
nous avons un cap qui est simple
finalement qui est très simple pour les
élections municipales c'est nous
contestons la politique du gouvernement
parce qu'elle n'est pas une politique de
bush
eh bien nous voulons dans les communes
pouvoir mener des politiques de bush
donc nous travaillons à cela là où il
existe des majorités de gauche là où
nous voudrions les conquérir et on
essaye de le faire on rassemblant le
plus largement possible et quand c'est
quand les conditions sont créées pour le
faire avec des socialistes qui acceptent
des objectifs de gauche et bien nous le
faisons comme appareil et donc il n'y a
aucune volonté de se détourner de la
stratégie du front gauche là dedans il
ya une application dans la bataille
municipale de 7,2 cette stratégie-là au
tenant compte des rapports de force
locaux alors évidemment ça provoque du
débat chez même chez les communistes
normal mais pourquoi mais pourquoi
pourquoi est ce que vous voudriez qu'il
en soit autrement
on a une politique gouvernementale qui
est désastreuse et qu'il prétendument
menée au nom de la gauche
donc il ya des gens qui sont déboussolés
par cette situation et nous nous disons
dans les élections municipales
on va pas abandonner le combat pour
autant c'est dire si l'audience est là
paris est symbolique vous avez faim à se
mettre sous les sous sous les
projecteurs et larry vous êtes nom est
associé au ps et vous allez vous
retrouver face au pg qui plaisante mais
ce qui est symbolique en ce moment à
paris c'est qu'effectivement dans la
capitale de la france la gauche est en
transe engagé à dire en tout cas la
liste dans laquelle nous allons aller
nous allons faire 30 % de logements
sociaux alors qu'on vient à peine
d'atteindre 20%
nous allons continuer à construire
encore plus de crèches que nous l'avons
fait alors que le gouvernement lui dis
moi je vais réduire de 3 milliards et
demi le budget de la sécurité sociale
qu'à paris vendredi dernier
anne hidalgo a dit sur la sphère
leonarda exactement la même chose que
moi et que mes camarades communistes
parisiens donc effectivement il ya une
singularité dans la situation parisienne
c'est que les forces du parti communiste
du parti socialiste s'engage en ce
moment à mener une politique de haut je
ne suis pas naïf je sais bien que ça
sera un combat
y compris avec avec les socialistes
c'est simple réveillons nous avons deux
premières médailles
nous avons des points de désaccord sur
certains points aussi et dans les
mandats précédents nous avons eu des
débats y compris dans la majorité
municipale mais nous avons réussi à
faire progresser les choses vers une
politique de gauche et je pense que nous
sommes en train d'en créer les
conditions grâce à la manière dont les
communismes la bataille appareils donc
nous nous tournons pas le dos au front
gauche loin s'en faut
nous essayons lui donner des atouts
supplémentaires ça faire des batailles
avoir une candidate
du parti de gauche qui va même prendre
l'enseigne front de gauche apparaît
alors oui mais mais nous aussi nous
sommes dans le front gauche qui va y
avoir à paris fusion non il va pas y
avoir de confusion il ya un débat qui
est transparent qui est sur la table les
électeurs sont majeurs ils entendent les
arguments que nous mettrons sur la table
les arguments que d'autres mettre sur la
table
ils feront leur choix ce sera la
démocratie et j'ai dit vous avez quitté
front de gauche en vous alliez en ps sur
paris mais google cocher au tac à
quitter le rocher a fait quatre ans ça
fait quatre ans que jour et nuit que
jour et nuit
je m'occupe de développer le front de
gauche je vais pas comme ça du jour au
lendemain car les chiens alors que je
pense alors que je pense que la
politique gouvernementale est très
mauvaise et qui va falloir continuer à
travailler à une alternative à ce
gouvernement et à sa politique
donc c'est pas moi qui vais quitter le
front de gauche après tout ce que j'ai
fait pour le développer donc c'est
ridicule cette idée là je par contre
effectivement je veux que dans la
bataille municipale
on engrange tout ce qu'il est possible y
compris pour se donner de la force pour
mener la campagne nationale contre la
sonel est ce que vous voyez que c'est
très lisible que vous soyez associés au
ps à paris et face au ps dans d'autres
grandes villes
eh bien il sait mais parce que regarder
la situation à marseille
vous croyez qu'elle est la même qu'à
pareille semaine il s'agit de conquérir
il s'agit de conquérir la ville contre
la droite avec un danger de front
national et regarder le spectacle
désolant que donne la primaire
socialiste donc effectivement à
marseille nous nous y prenons autrement
mais nous avons le même objectif
nous nous y prenons trop parce qu'à
marseille si ya pas une force comme la
nôtre qui à l'initiative du front de
gauche 10 aux marseillais
vous voulez pas de ce spectacle
politique vous voulez une gauche digne
et une gauche qui s'occupe de vos
problèmes et pas de la guerre des égos
entre des candidats à la primaire eh
bien nous nous allons construire ses
listes aulas donc effectivement il ya
des villes où on s'y prend pas de la
même manière mais l'objectif est pour
moi exactement le même apparemment ce
n'est pas si clair que ça pour jean luc
mélenchon et est-ce que ça risque pas de
faire éclater le front de gauche toutes
ces bisbilles après midi
évidemment je souhaite de tout mon coeur
qu'il n'en soit pas ainsi dans les avoir
d un débat avec jean luc mélenchon sur
ce point mais moi je lui dis et je le
redis aujourd'hui
ce débat ne justifie pas loin s'en faut
un quelconque éclatement du front de
gauche nous avons eu d'autres aux débats
depuis le début du front de gauche et
nous avons continué a franchi à franchir
les étapes ensemble pour le moment ce
que je constate c'est que la majorité
des organisations du front de gauche 10
la très grande majorité la
quasi-totalité 10 effectivement nous
avons un débat sur les municipales dans
certaines villes mais ça ne justifie pas
de mettre en cause l'avenir du front de
gauche
c'est aussi ce que je dis avec mes
camarades communistes
donc il faut qu'on surmonte ce débat
qu'on l'assument et puis qu'on continue
à travailler ensemble et on a une très
bonne occasion de le faire parce qu'il
ya des élections européennes quasiment
en même temps
et là nous avons une ligne claire qui
nous rassemble tous
on vient moi je suis président du parti
de la gauche européenne de désigner
comme candidat commun pour nous être ne
porte parole au niveau de l'europe
alexis tsipras sq et les leaders de
syriza en grèce nous avons une très
bonne occasion de mener une campagne
nationale seront toujours sur les
européennes
d'ailleurs il dit qu'il n'a plus aucun
contact avec vous sur les européennes
depuis le mois de juin qui est plus
d'interlocuteur il ya une réunion qui se
tient tous les lundi matins
on continue de se tenir à la
coordination nationale du front sans
vous sans gêne à laquelle non c'est pas
vrai moi j'y participe très
régulièrement parler et pas ces
dernières semaines mais à cette réunion
nous discutons toute cette question et
il est prévu que le quai lundi 4
novembre puisque ça a lieu tous les
lundis nous allons avoir une discussion
sur les futures élections européennes
donc voila nous commençons au débat mais
chez trécarré et nous publions et nous
publions demain une déclaration de notre
comité exécutif national du parti
communiste qui dit il faut maintenant
aller vite dans la constitution des
listes aux élections européennes et être
prêt à la fin de l'année pour mener les
deux batailles en commun celle des
municipales et seulement dans la masse
vous prenez un peu du poil de la bête
face à jean luc mélenchon qui très joli
présent j'ai jamais eu l'impression de
ne pas avoir dépassé les médias qui
raconte ça mais moi j'ai toujours joué
mon rôle dans le front de gauche
j'ai toujours eu ma place et j'ai jamais
fait de complexe
en quoi que ce soit dans la conduite du
front de gauche donc jean luc mélenchon
à lui développé un complexe de
supériorité
non je ne crois pas à nous à nous avons
mené une bataille très belle bataille
commune ensemble dans l'élection
présidentielle mais je pense que nous
sommes des forces différentes unis dans
un front mais différente
il ya des débats politiques il n'y a
aucune raison de dramatiser cd napoli
pas sur les municipales c'est pas plus
profond que ça c'est aussi un débat sur
l'avenir du front de gauche sur une
vision chacun qui n'est pas forcément la
même sur ce que doit devenir le front de
gauche je crois qu'il ya un débat
sérieux oui sur qu'est ce qu'elle est
nous sommes dans une nouvelle situation
politique depuis la victoire de françois
hollande
et à partir du moment où on voit bien
que le gouvernement tourne le dos à ce
qu'il aurait dû être une politique de
gauche
nous avons un défi politique nouveau à
remplir parce que pour nous maintenant
il s'agit pas seulement de réunir ceux
qui ont voté front gauche
il faut qu'on se tourne vers des
millions de gens qui ont voté françois
hollande et qui ne se reconnaissent pas
dans la politique gouvernementale
donc comment est-ce qu'on résout ce
problème comment est ce qu'on fait ça
provoque effectivement un débat nouveau
dans le front de gauche qui n'existait
pas avant
et on a des différends sur la manière
dont on aborde cette question pour moi
ces différences ne justifie sûrement pas
l'éclatement du front gauche parce que
de toute façon nous sommes condamnés à
relever ce défi politique parce que
c'est la seule manière d'empêcher le
retour de la droite voire le progrès de
l'extrême droite c'est de recréer un
espoir à gauche
au moment où le gouvernement lui tourne
pas mal justement dans une année
électorale municipale européenne et au
final on se rend compte sur les
élections intermédiaires c'est pas le
front de gauche c'est plutôt
effectivement le fn qui récupère les
voies les voix des mécontents mais
actuellement actuellement ce qui se
passe et qui a un double phénomène
il ya un phénomène de démobilisation à
gauche à cause de la politique
gouvernementale
il ya un phénomène de radicalisation à
droite au faveur de l'extrême droite
mais parce que
l'ump a ouvert les vannes et on le voit
bien avec copé sur le droit du sol dit
alors mais si nous créons l'espoir mais
sous nous recréons l'espoir à gauche et
il faut le faire avec le front de gauche
c'est bien nous pouvons résoudre cette
question parce que les gens qui ont
voulu le changement en 2012 n'ont ni
abandonner leur valeur ni abandonner
leurs attentes ni abandonner leurs
espoirs
alors on où tout reste au possible avec
le front on a vu votre camarade tout à
l'heure dans le sujet de faustine sa
jeunesse ian brossât qui est important
la qpc et qui deviendra le porte parole
de la socialiste anne hidalgo a paris il
a poussé rec le porte parole d'eads et
des communistes dont la compagne la
sonde coalition radiant pour paris et il
a poussé pour un voeux de la
municipalité
avec 4 1 de l'année pour en faveur des
roms et on se souvient qu'il a demandé
un village d'insertion dans le 16e
arrondissement
mais le maire lui a promis un retour
d'accorder aux roms
les logements vides de la ville de paris
c'est une bonne idée
je crois que vous savez le pro sur le
problème des roms
mais sur cette question sont situés sur
le oui mais parce que sur le problème
des roms ce qui manque c'est tout
simplement c'est une politique d'accueil
nationale qui parce qu'on parle bien ça
est à 18000 personnes pour la france
s'est largement paris qu'ils soient sans
ce qu'est ce que vous dites aux
habitants de la région parisienne qui
attendent depuis des années un logement
social
nb nous est d'une santé mais seulement
nous sommes c'est pas à nous qu'il faut
dire ça nous nous battons depuis depuis
deux mandats pour mettre à la question
de la construction des logements sociaux
au premier rang des priorités de la
ville et nous l'avons obtenu et nous
obtenons que maintenant ses objectifs
soit amplifiée en corse tandis que la
droite tandis que la droite appareils
par exemple se bat contre le moindre le
joueur social qui doit être construit
dès qu' un projet de logement social que
veut faire la ville de paris dans le
xvième ils font des recours à n'en plus
finir pour empêcher la construction de
ces logements sociaux
c'est quand même pas eux qui vont venir
nous donner des leçons sur la politique
de logement social à paris
allez merci catalan va cueillir les
internautes public sénat maintenant pour
la troisième partie d'émission
paris n'arrive pour évoquer donc
d'autres réformes qui n'ont pas l'air de
vous plaire
déjà bien entendu depuis le début de
cette émission mais on va d'abord voir
comment votre base sociale et
électriques râler je fais des
propositions contre la finance
particulier absolue on va voir comment
votre base est grignotée par le front
national justement qui parmi ces villes
cibles désignées pour les prochaines
municipales notamment retenu des
communes qui sont gérés de longue date
par le parti communiste français c'est
un exemple par exemple de mitry mory en
seine-et-marne qu'a choisi marie brémaud
mitry mory commune industrielle de 20000
habitants aux grandes banlieues
parisiennes en seine et marne mitry mory
ville communiste depuis 50 ans mais à
l'élection présidentielle le fn a
surpassé le front de gauche avec 22,4
pour cent des voix alors à quelques mois
des municipales le tout jeune candidat
frontiste de 24 ans seuls la charge
depuis 50 ans elles sont votées
communiste depuis 50 ans cela ne bouge
pas à part dans la négativité et c'est
pourquoi de plus en plus nous montons de
plus en plus nous arrivons est de plus
en plus nos soins m
une offensive sur une ville cible mais
pour l'heure le programme du front
national est encore bien floue pour la
mer est candidate à sa succession
corinne dupont la meilleure défense à
l'attaqué
c'est son bilan et le silence et je ne
sais pas ce que veut dire être une cible
moi je sais quelque chose qui ne
m'intéresse pas non c'est sans réponse
sans réponse le fn qui chasse sur des
territoires communiste pour les experts
cela n'a rien d'étonnant à c'est aussi
ça qui est visé c'est à dire
d'apparaître comme l'alternance en
milieu populaire vous la seule
alternative à la gauche c'est le front
national puisque historiquement dans ces
communes
l'ump où les partis qui n'ont constitué
ont toujours été réduit au rôle de
figuration à mitry-mory adrien des ports
espère au minimum cinq conseillers
municipaux
c'est vrai qu'il ya une note la semaine
dernière des services du ministère de
l'intérieur qui alerté sur une société
de plus en plus inflammable
une colère qui une colère qui s'exprime
non pas dans la rue mais dans les urnes
est-ce que petit à petit le front
national grignote ces voix populaire
mais écoutez il ya une situation du pays
qui est très inquiétante et c'est le
résultat de quoi de dix ans de politique
de droite qui ont multiplié le chômage
la précarité la pauvreté qui ont cassé
les solidarités qui les ont cassé
concrètement et qui les ont cassé dans
les têtes ont développé des idées et
d'égoïsme de repli de xénophobie
et puis maintenant une politique de
gauche est maintenant dans une politique
socialiste du gouvernement socialiste
qui au lieu de prendre le taureau par
les cornes et de faire ce qui était
promis c'est à dire on va s'attaquer au
pouvoir de la finance on va mieux
répartir les richesses
on va faire de la solidarité fait le
contraire donc il ya un moment où les
gens se disent alors il ya plus rien à
faire donc il faut à ce moment là que
des forces se lève et c'est ce que nous
faisons pour organiser justement cette
solidarité pour montrer qu'il est
possible de mener des politiques élèves
est-ce que vous avez du mal à avoir des
gens dans la rue dans vos manifestations
on a l'impression que la classe
politique les syndicalistes sont
impuissants aujourd'hui qui coûtait bien
joué c'est ce que la f1 c'est ce côté ce
qu'on passe son temps à c'est ce qu'on
répète en permanence pour évacuer le
débat sur les responsabilités parce que
on peut voter demain matin un projet de
loi pour interdire les licenciements
boursiers
quand nous étions dans l'opposition
socialistes communistes et verts nous
l'avons voté ensemble pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne veut pas par manque de courage
politique
voilà tout simplement mais il existe
demain matin dès majorité à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat qui peuvent voter
ces lois là nous pouvons très bien au
lieu de faire la politique fiscale qu'on
est en train de faire on peut très bien
mettre les moyens pour aller chercher
les 50 milliards d'évasion fiscale
on peut très bien contrôler les fonds
publics qu'on distribue aux entreprises
alors qu'ils s'en servent pour licencier
donc il ya aucune raison ou à jouer je
conteste l'idée de l'impuissance fiction
d'impuissance politique contrairement à
ce qu'on dit aux gens et c'est une
question qu'il faut avoir le courage de
s'attaquer au pouvoir de la finance
quand françois hollande disait au
bourget s'il y en a
et bien il maintenant il faut le faire
du coup est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec jean luc mélenchon quand il dit que
finalement à la politique du parti
socialiste est presque pire que celle de
l'ump
en tout cas c'est c'est pas une
politique de gauche là dessus moi je
peux aider dans certains domaines
elle est en train d'aggraver elle est en
train d'aggraver la situation voit avec
la réforme des retraites
on avait la réforme sarkozy on avait dit
on va la combattre
au lieu de la corriger on rallonge
encore les années de cotisations mais
les camions qu'on va faire si un cas
structurelles vers cette réforme sur les
retraites elle va conduire à ce qu'on
partira à nouveau plus tard avec des
retraites et des pensions encore
dégradée voilà le résultat
parce qu'avec plus en compte la
pénibilité par exemple dont elle elle
dit qu'elle prend en compte la
pénibilité mais quand on passe aux
dispositifs concrets de prise en compte
de la pénibilité on est à des kilomètres
de ce que demande aux organisations ce
qui est sûr qu'à trois reprises qu'il y
aura un contenu ibilité oui mais il y a
des il y a des il y a des la seule chose
nouvelle c'est qu'on inscrit ce principe
là dans la loi mais pour ce qui est des
dispositifs concrets qui vont permettre
d'accéder à une véritable reconnaissance
de la pénibilité dans le projet de loi
on est très loin du compte
et d'ailleurs si le gouvernement veut
rendre ça plus concret il pourra très
bien reprendre nos amendements dans le
débat qui démarre lundi oscillant le
voir parce qu on va pas manquer
d'amender le projet sur cette question
et sur la question de la jeunesse sur la
question des retraites des femmes et sur
beaucoup d'autres questions quelques 200
amendements attendu
de votre groupe effectivement sur sur ce
projet de loi retraites vous confirmer
qu'au sénat vous ne voterez ni le projet
de loi sur les retraites ni le projet de
loi ni la loi de finances ni la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ne
voteront pas le projet de loi sur les
retraites elle qui nous arrive ça c'est
clair et net nous allons déposer vous
dit à peu près 200 amendements nous
avions un groupe ce matin c'est à peu
près ça eh bien nous attendons donc ces
amendements soir prince y on nous laisse
ici comme à l'assemblée nationale on
nous retourne tous ses amendements nous
votre rencontre et sur le budget nous
votre compte pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'on nous propose encore de nous
enfoncer dans une logique budgétaire qui
n'améliore pas la situation du pays ne
permet pas de croissance ne résout pas
les inégalités et en plus nos réseaux
même pas les déficits
faudrait pas non plus la prochaine voici
maison parce que nous sommes toujours
dans la même logique
toujours dans la même logique qui
continue à faire des cadeaux toujours ou
même et à ne pas résoudre les problèmes
les problèmes d'inégalité sociale car
laurent ça ça va être logique mal à vous
comprendrez que peut-être les électeurs
français soit un peu perdus quand ils
vous voient nouer des alliances avec le
parti socialiste même sont pour des
élections locales mais on s'est
expliqués et parce que quand qu'il ya
une politique gouvernementale
comprenez qu'il refuse assez du coût des
partis politiques français chien oui
mais attendez c'est tout ce qu'on sait
de 1604 des positionnements tacler
socialo justement c'est exactement le
contraire en ce qui nous concerne c'est
qu'on nous demande de nous enfermer dans
des postures politiques politiciennes a
priori et nous nous disons exactement
contraire parce que nous mais parce que
notre boussole n'est pas celle que sur
laquelle vous m'interrogez en permanence
les alliances
moi ma boussole c est ce que ce qu'on
fait va être utile aux populations pas
et à paris c est ce qu aura du logement
social
est-ce qu'on va lutter contre la
spéculation est-ce qu'on va construire
des crèches pour répondre est-ce qu'il
va est ce qu'on va faire des transports
publics et cette question là les
attendait ça depuis 2001
oui absolument l'équipe de bertrand
delanoë et grâce justement au travail
des communistes dans cette majorité a
fait par exemple de la construction de
logement social une de ses grandes
priorités
je rappelle que quand de la delanoë a
gagné la ville
en 2001 il y avait dans le programme de
delanoë l'idée de construire 3000
logements sociaux par an
nous nous en propose ion plus à l'époque
et aujourd'hui on en construit cinq à
six mille par an grâce à la bataille que
nous avons menées et avec l'objectif qui
est retenu dans l'accord que nous avons
passé avec anne hidalgo
ce sera plus de 7000 logements sociaux
par an voilà ça c'est du concret et nous
c'est ce qui nous déterminent c'est pas
avec les alliances les postures et c'est
assez justement exactions étaient à
matignon alors là vous seriez derrière
là bas si elle était à matignon pour
prendre cet exemple je pense que cette
hypothèse ne ne se présente pas mais si
elle ou une autre et visait je change
totalement la politique du gouvernement
actuel pour en faire une autre mais on
discuterait le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui quand il s'agit de
discuter la politique gouvernementale
du côté de des dirigeants actuels du
parti socialiste pour le moment il ya
personne pour venir on va faire ça et
donc nous ne pouvons pas prêter la main
à cette politique qui va dans le mur
mais quand dans une commune il est
possible d'avancer dans ce sens là et
bien nous nous saisissons l'occasion
parce que précisément ce qui nous
intéresse c'est ce qui se passe pour les
jeunes arrivés par d'autres agriculteurs
sont mobilisés aujourd'hui contre le
projet d'écotaxe qui rentrera en vigueur
le 1er janvier 2014
est-ce qu'il faut la supprimer ou la
maintenir cette écotaxe et le problème
de cette écotaxe c'est qu'elle est elle
est une fois de plus elle et elle est
injuste telle qu'elle est conçue par ce
qu'elle va frapper des jo au niveau de
la consommation alors qu'en vérité il
faudrait prendre le problème de
l'écologie en amont parce qu'il faut une
politique écologique mais il faut se re
et transport apprécié de favoriser des
matches denses parce qu'ils soient moins
voyants ont le cul roos vous dit à des
gens nous vous donnons aucun moyen de
changer vos moyens de transport de les
renouveler parce que on sait que les
agriculteurs ont des problèmes de
revenus importants vous êtes obligés de
renouveler votre matériel et la seule
chose qu'on fait c'est qu'on vous taxe
halal
si on veut que les utilisent
des moyens des moyens moins polluants et
bien à ce moment là on les aide à
changer d'équipement ont créé les
conditions pour qu'il change
d'équipements aux finances des nouveaux
équipements et on aide les agriculteurs
à moderniser dans un sens écologique
leur matériel et leur mode de production
on s'attaque à la racine du problème
là on le fait pas on dit qu'on fait ça
on fait rien du tout on les laisse dans
la même difficulté et on les taxe à la
sortie c'est le sait mais même les verts
sont ne sont pas très contre 6 initiés
défense assez d'initiatives du grenelle
de la norme écouter j'écoute ce que
disent les verts je discute beaucoup
avec eux je n'ai pas l'oppression s'il
saute de joie c'est avec joie devant la
politique écologique du gouvernement
accord s'ils n'arrêtent pas de dire que
cette politique écologique n'est pas
mais on n'est pas ta n'est pas il pose
aussi les conditions sur les côtes ouest
sur le scandale de l'espionnage des
services secrets américains vers
l'europe vers notamment la france vous
demander à ce que la france sorte de
l'otan mais ce que voulait aussi qu'on
mette fin à toute coordination
coopération de lutte contre le
terrorisme mais écouter quels étaient
les quel est le rapport
quel rapport est ce que vous payez que
son esprit autres tous les français qui
utilisent les communications des
communications téléphoniques qu'on va
lutter contre le terrorisme à france 4 à
la base problème est un problème très
sérieux des rapports entre la france et
les états unis
surtout que cette affaire n'est pas la
première on en est déjà aux trois au
quatrième incident lourd quand même je
parle même pas de l'arrêt de l'avion
d'evo morales et et autres et autres
incidents diplomatiques
jusqu'à quand on va se faire humilier
par un pays qu'ils inondent à droite
surveiller tout le monde on fait ce
qu'on veut
personne n'a le droit de nous demander
des comptes et puis non continue
d'accepter ça et on accepte de
s'intégrer dans le commandement
militaire intégré de l'otan sous
responsabilité des américains et on n'a
pas notre mot à dire
moi j'ai connu même à droite quand même
des dirigeants politiques qui avaient un
peu plus de dignité pour faire respecter
la parole dollars pour faire quoi j'en
ai faudra mettre en cause notamment les
accords de libre échange
oui il faut non seulement il faut
remettre en cause ce qui existe mais il
faut surtout pas aller vers ce qu'on
nous propose en europe
le pacte transatlantique le traité
du grand marché transatlantique qui
préconise de libéraliser tous les
échanges et qui va ouvrir en fait nos
marchés aux états unis sans aucune sans
aucune contrepartie d'ailleurs de
dignité demandez vous à la démo l'état
mais il a eu un échange vif dit on avec
marc accos miceli sa réprobation oxylane
laisser la moindre des changes comme un
des célèbres de chômer puisque ont
commencé à la discussion sur le temps je
pense que nous devrions développer une
politique de la france plus indépendante
et qui n'attendent pas le feu vert des
états unis pour décider ce qu'elle fait
dans telle ou telle région question oui
ou non c'est vrai vous parlez plus du
tout avec jean luc mélenchon tu cet été
vous avez pas répondu que cela m'était
où on reprenait les images avaient
publié même à la fête de l'humanité on a
à plusieurs reprises
on s'est croisé ensemble a fait de vous
croiser si vous vous parlez on a compris
qu'un rendez vous était prévu au début
du 20 novembre le 3 ou 4 le 4 novembre
pour discuter sur les élections
européennes a atteint ses limites